Musik In die Membran, du.
In die Membran.
Das ist wie mit einer Glühbeeren.
Du musst das Mikro schütteln.
Genau.
Und dann musst du gucken, wenn da was wackelt, dann ist es feile.
Freunde der Membran.
Freunde der guten Laune.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Damen und Herren.
Hey.
Zur Folge 49.
Wir sind wieder da.
Wir haben uns durch den öffentlichen Druck natürlich niederschlagen lassen, um uns zu wieder hingesetzt natürlich. Und ganz im Ernst, was war letzte
Woche los? Wir haben uns in Folge 48 geschafft, das Mikrofon falsch herumzuordnen.
Ich habe es mir hinter den Kopf gehalten tatsächlich.
Du hast ja einen Handstand gemacht, warum?
Ja, ich dachte, das ist mal was Neues. Nein, kommen wir gleich zu unserer ersten Rubrik, der Wap, wap, wap, wap, wap Mea Culpa, sorry, und natürlich die letzte Folge, die wir leider, ja, wie ein ungewolltes Hündchen leider in den Mülleimer werfen mussten, weil wir es einfach nicht hingekriegt haben, das 49. Mal für mich aufzunehmen. Wir haben da noch Experten dran gesetzt, die konnten auch nichts machen, aber ein Team von CERN, was so ein Taskforce gegründet hat, in so weissen Kitteln, haben die mit Reagenzlesern so Versuche mit der Folge gemacht. Genau, wir haben extra die Schallplatte dahingeschickt, wir wissen nicht, ob sie nicht vielleicht untergegangen ist, aber mal kommen. Vielleicht, nicht ausreichend frankiert. Auf jeden Fall. Aber es ist echt kein Scherz, du hast einfach nur falsch ins Mikro gesprochen. Ich habe falsch ins Mikro gesprochen. Ich habe eine Idee. Wir haben deine Nils-Boom-Hoff-Folge noch und meine Spur hiervon noch. Wir schneiden die einfach zusammen und möglicherweise, weil beide Folgen waren nicht gut, vielleicht sind die beide zusammen lustig. Genau, bei der Nies-Pumov-Folge hast du deine Spur gelöscht und jetzt ist meine Spur unbrauchbar. Das ist geil, ich glaube, das machen wir. Machen wir Folge 50, das grosse Jubiläum, die Mash-Up-Folge. Also es klang, um das mal zu demonstrieren, es klang dann so ungefähr, wenn ihr jetzt sagt, das klingt auch gar nicht so schlecht, dann kennt ihr nicht die hohen Ansprüche, die wir jeden Tag an unsere eigene Arbeit hier setzen. Die ihr auch irgendwie geschürt habt, weil ihr wollt ja immer gute Audioqualität. Wir wollen mehr, noch besser, noch besser, noch besser. Wir wollen sie verstehen, wenn wir da bei Zwieback essen. Genau, ja, ja, ja, die alten Gags, die alten Gags waren auch nicht schlecht. Aber damit ihr jetzt nicht denkt, ach scheisse, wir haben was verpasst, kommen hier nochmal für euch im Schnelldurchlauf die letzten, die besten drei Gags aus der letzten Folge, vielleicht könnt ihr kein Wort verstehen. Hast du die aufgeschrieben? Ne, überhaupt nicht, das wirst du schneiden müssen, mein Lieber. Alles klar, wir müssen uns überlegen, was die besten, ich habe die Geschichte erzählt. Die besten Dope, Dope war dabei, oder? Ja, möcht ich kurz erzählen? Nee, nein. Ach so. Die wird die reinschneiden. Das wird die reinschneiden. Du kannst jetzt nicht deine Story nochmal erzählen. Und ich mach denselben spontanen Gag. Ich mach dich im Schnelldurchlauf kurz. Nein, nein, nein, wir schneiden die rein. Wir schneiden die im Schnelldurchlauf rein. Aber dann hat man deine Spur ja nicht. Also man hört mich gleich einfach nur reden. Ja, man hört mich halt schlecht. So vierte Wand mässig. Ich bräch die vierte Wand. Weißt du, aus welchen Gründen wie diesen besprechen wir solche Dinge vor der Aufnahme? Und ich dachte eigentlich, du hättest es verstanden, weil du mich die bielgrinsend nickend angeschaut hast, während du dir das siebte Milky Way ins Gesicht geschoben hast. Da dachte ich eigentlich, das wäre bei dir angekommen. Aber Fehlanzeige tatsächlich mal wieder. Stefan Moretti, das funktioniert so nicht. Wir haben uns noch gar nicht vorgestellt. Heute, er ist gerade angekommen, er ist gelandet, vor 45 Minuten hier in Köln, kommt er gerade, er ist um die ganze Welt gereist, heute ist er hier, der Globetrotter Stefan Titzer. Schönen guten Abend, er war die ganze Zeit hier, weil er abends auch nicht, er geht nicht mehr nach Hause. Leute, Kollegen sagen schon, Florentin, willst du nicht nach Hause? Und er sagt, ich habe zu Hause doch nichts. Er wohnt jetzt hier in Köln.
Herzlich willkommen, Florentin
will. Vielen Dank, dankeschön.
Und ist das tatsächlich keine Lüge, du warst gerade
unterwegs. Wo kommst du denn her? Ich komme aus München, ich habe
einen Freund besucht, der da ein Praxissemester macht.
Und das war echt
geil. Jetzt Achtung
für drei Anekdoten, Entschuldigung.
Skippt schon mal auf Minute zwölf, Leute.
Ich habe mich hier als ersten Punkt aufgeschrieben, Stefan der Globetrotter,
Doppelpunkt, lustige Stories
vom Flughafen, Fragezeichen.
Es ist ein, das wir jetzt noch nicht mehr sehen,oppelpunkt, lustige Stories vom Flughafen, Fragezeichen. Kannst du da deliveren? Ich muss ganz demnach sagen, ich habe mich, ich habe davor so ein paar Jerry Seinfeld-Sachen geguckt und der hat, also der hat ja so diese Flughafen-Comedy erstmal so salonfähig gemacht. Nach Mario Barth, ja. Nach Mario Barth und Lurio und DJ Lobo. Und Lufthansa, ja. Die ist ja auch mehr ein Witz, oder? Die Preise sind ein Witz. Nee, der Service. Air Berlin. Dieser Podcast ist brought to you by Air Berlin. Und ich habe mich da wirklich darauf gefreut dann so, weil man ist halt die ganze Zeit so debil grinsend, weil man halt diese ganzen Gags im Kopf hat. Zum Beispiel, dass sie ja, was ja wirklich lustig ist, wenn man darauf achtet, dass sie einem immer noch erklären, wie man diese Schnalle aufmachen muss und wie man die zumacht. Und gut, du kennst den Gag jetzt vielleicht, aber ich bin sicher, draußen die Hörer von den Empfangsgeräten freuen sich jetzt darüber, dass man denen jetzt nochmal alles erklären kann. Welchen Gag jetzt genau? Dass die Schnallen, dass sie einem die Schnallen nochmal erklären. Das ist der Gag. Als ob man nach 60 Jahren gar nicht einmal im Auto gesessen hat. Ja, aber das sind ja dieselben Schnallen wie im Auto. Naja, schon. Nein. Also du drückst, du betätigst was. Aber ich verstehe jetzt wirklich, warum Flugangst verbreitet ist. Weil du halt wirklich anders behandelt wirst. Also du, im Zug erklärt niemand, wie du die Tür aufmachst und so und wo die Notausgänge sind. Im Zug musst du dich auch nicht anschnallen, ne? Nee, im Bus auch nicht. Aber das ist auch ein bisschen willkürlich, wann man sich anschnallen muss und wann nicht. Wann man einen Helm tragen muss und wann nicht. Das stimmt, ja. Ich muss zum Beispiel immer einen Helm tragen, oder nicht. Man müsste zum Beispiel sagen, in der U-Bahn muss man sich zwar nicht anschnallen, aber einen Helm tragen. Ich finde, man sollte einen U-Bahn tragen. Dafür im Flugzeug anschnallen, aber keinen Helm. Einfach zu jeder Zeit perfekt gesichert. Ja, und dann auch diese, vor allem diese Karte, die hier vor einem ist, wo wir dann sagen, alle Sicherheitsinformationen nehmen sie aus der Karte vor ihnen, wo dann diese Leute diese Safety-Position einnehmen. Safety-Dance auch, ja. Safety-Dance auch führen. Was bringt denn diese Position, wenn du mit 30.000 Lichtgeschwindigkeit in die Alpen krachst? Was bringt denn diese Position? Ich weiss es nicht, vielleicht ist es auch nur zur Beruhigung. Ich meine, laut Fight Club ist es dazu da, dass die Leute sich schnell das Genick brechen und dann die Fluggesellschaft sich die Versicherungskosten spart. Das könnte eine Verschwörungstheorie sein, ich weiss es nicht, es war in einem Film. So, wir kriegen Besuch, komm's rein, komm's rein. Oh Gott, der Blick ist nicht schlecht, dieser entnervte Blick. Ach Mensch, jetzt haben wir uns, wir dachten, dass wir könnten hier... Du musst hier rein, ne? Du musst hier rein. Ich wollte den Computer ausmachen, den wollte ich gar nicht machen. Ach, das ist in Ordnung. Hi, wie heisst du denn? Hallo, ich bin der neue Kai Zwei. Ja, so viele Leute, ich habe ja schon Timo kennen. Grüß dich, hi Stefan, hallo. Hi Stefan, hallo. Ach geil, und du bist der neue Tonenmann. Ja, genau. Ach toll. Kannst du unsere Folge vielleicht retten retten von letzte Woche? Weil Kai schafft es nicht. Und ich würde gerne, also wir haben nämlich eine, er hat das Mikrofon falsch rumgehalten und Kai schafft es nicht. Hinten ins Mikrofon reingesprochen und es klang doch total beschissen. Und ich finde es ganz gut, wenn man so intern so einen Harnkampf euch gegeneinander auffällt, weil wir… Genau, wer ist besser, so ein Du? Ja, genau. So ein Ring. Ähm, wie war es? Bing, bing, bing, bing. Äh, also es klingt, es wird nicht also es wird nicht gut klingen. Ja, aber das ist egal, laut! Es geht ja um die Gags, also ist das Lachen trotzdem noch vorhanden, oder? Also ob die Leute trotzdem noch lachen können, meinst du? Ja, ja. Die müssen wir anhören, ich weiss nicht, wie stark das Mikrofon richtet. Du hörst halt da nur Bass, ne, von der Rückseite. Aber doch, Furti hat jetzt eine sehr hohe Stimme, vielleicht gleicht sich das denn aus. Nein, ich habe keine, ich habe eine sehr tiefe Stimme. Ich habe eine schöne tiefe Stimme. Aber glaubst du, dass unsere Gags auch gut genug sind, dass selbst durch die technischen Makulaturen da noch was übrig bleibt? Ich müsste es mir anhören, ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Okay, wir schicken es dir auch mal und wir zeigen den Hörern dann beide Versionen und dann haben wir endlich mal klar, wer der bessere Tonmann ist von euch beiden. Ja, genau. Dann wird das direkt mal klar. Und ich gebe es dann auch in die Geschäftsleitung weiter dann direkt. Ja, bitte. Cool. Warum kommen jetzt plötzlich so viele neue Tonleute hier? Ich habe Timo schon getroffen, dich, was ist los mit den alten? Timo ist der Praktikant, er ist auch der neue Praktikant, das ist der neue Evo sozusagen. Aber was war denn mit den alten Tonleuten falsch? Oder heißen wir jetzt Bild, Ton und Tonfabrik? Ich war jetzt im letzten Jahreshälfte war ich einfach so oft hier und habe hier jede Woche was gemacht. Habe ich nie gesehen. Habe ich nie gesehen. Tonleute sind sehr unscheinbar, kann das sein? Man hört sie nur. Ich habe halt hauptsächlich Duelf gemacht. Ach so, okay, gut. Und hier am Donnerstag morgens finalisiert. Machst du auch Musik? Da liegt alle mit dem Kader am Bett. Stimmt. Ja. Was machst du mit Musik? Schlagzeuge. Schlagzeuge, aber welche Musikrichtung? Ähm, Free Jazz. Alles. Alles, alles, alles was Geiles in Eier hat. Was ist dein Lieblingstrommel? Die Snare. Nein, die Bombo. Die Kickdrum. Die Kickdrum. Erst die Kickdrum, dann die Hi-Hat und dann die Snare doch. Nein, die Bombo. Die Kickdrum. Die Kickdrum. Die ist schon ganz geil. Erst die Kickdrum, dann die Hi-Hat und dann die Snare. Was ist dein Lieblings-Urschungs? Spielst du mit drei oder zwei Hänge-Toms? Mal mit einem, mal mit zwei, mal mit drei. Wie findest du das Interview bis jetzt? Findest du gut oder stellen wir die richtigen Fragen? Nehmen wir das auf? Wir nehmen auf, ja, wir sind mitten in der Aufnahme tatsächlich. Aber wir können das auch rausschneiden. Das Interview ist interessant. Ich frage es, ob man sich noch höher interessiert, wie viele Toms ich habe und vor allen Dingen, wie sehr die hängen oder stehen. Ich finde, du hast eine sehr angenehme Stimmung. Wenn du das Mikro richtig rumgehalten hast, was wir nicht wissen, zu diesem jetzigen Zeitpunkt. Ich habe heute bemerkt, dass es sich selten lohnt, die Namen von Tonleuten zu merken. Ich bin tatsächlich, also immer von den anderen merke ich es mir, immer von Tonleuten aber nicht. Ich bin mittlerweile so weit, ich merke mir von Praktikanten die Namen nicht mehr. Ja, das ist ja schon schön, wenn man merkt, dass man abgehoben ist. Ich komme rein, ich sage Hallo und dann stelle ich mich vor kurz. Also ist dir aufgefallen, dass Praktikanten immer so absurd abgefahrene Namen haben? Ich glaube auch, das ist irgendwie so Filmpolitik, dass nicht irgendwie Leute, die Manelisa oder so eingestellt werden, wegen Quote und so einem Kram, sondern dass es dann immer so eine Ottolino-Tour oder so ein Kram ist, damit er auch keinen vernünftigen Spitznamen haben. Ja. Wie heißt der Praktikant aus dem Ton? Timo. Ja gut, aber das ist halt ein Tonpraktikant, da kannst du dich drauf annehmen. Das kann man sich auch nicht merken. Hat er irgendwie ein Hobby, was man sich irgendwie, wo, Pikachu, Gehörgung machen. Techno, Techno-Timo. Stefan, eine Frage, wie heißt er?
Er hat vorhin beim Reingehen seinen Namen genannt. Wie heißt er? Ich hasse dich, weil ich das Riesenproblem, was ich habe. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem.
Wenn ihr da draußen wisst, wie der gute Ton mal heisst, schreibt eine Postkarte, Postfach das Podcast-Uvo, um herauszufinden, wie Tom heisst.
Ich habe ein Riesenproblem. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem.
Tom Tom.
Tja, das ist die Kunst.
Weisst du, da merkt man, der Unterschied zwischen dem Stefan Tingo und dem Florentin Willis, dass ich mir noch dem einzelnen Leuten... Ich hätte ihn, wenn du rausgegangen wärst, hätte ich ihn nochmal gefragt, wie du heisst. Echt, das tut mir echt leid. Das meine ich wirklich nicht böse. Aber wie scheisse findest du das jetzt, dass er den Namen vergessen hat? Das meine ich eigentlich. Das ist völlig in Ordnung. Weisst du noch, wie ich heiss? Stefan. Scheisse. Ich finde Ordnung, wenn man Namen vergisst, weil ich habe nur so ein autogenes Training gemacht, in dem man dann Leute auf die Leute zugeht und sie anguckt und den Namen wiederholt laut. Wer bist du? Stefan? Hallo Stefan. Hallo. So, und dadurch merkt man sich das. Aber es gibt halt auch Personen, von denen hörst du den Namen fünfmal oder so. Am Geisterzug habe ich wieder eine Mädel getroffen, die habe ich erst gar nicht erkannt, weil sie eine Perücke aufhatte, obwohl ich die schon 20 Mal gesehen habe und sich jedes Mal neu vorgestellt habe und sie musste sich wieder vorstellen. Gestern war es die Ausrede, weil sie hat eine Perücke auf und ich habe sie nicht erkannt. Dohe Ausrede. Kathi, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es mir gemerkt. Jetzt habe ich es mir gemerkt. In der Uni mussten wir uns vorstellen, weil es angeblich dann besser merkbar ist, dass man sich ein Adjektiv mit seinen Anfangsbuchstaben ausdenkt. Zum Beispiel der Stammfunde Stefan. Das ist kein Adjektiv! Das ist ein Verb. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Nur weil es halt genau so anfängt. Also, und du wärst ja trödelnde Timo, Tom.
Ich bin der freche Floristin.
Ich bin manchmal ein bisschen frech, aber nur manchmal.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist ein Adjektiv.
Ja, alles klar, dankeschön.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Der PC ist aus, ist ein bisschen...
Wir sehen uns ja sowieso, ne?
Hau rein.
Wir sehen uns, also wenn ich innerhalb der Probezeit überhaupt Lust habe, weiter zu sagen. Gibt es irgendwo so einen Tontechniker-Gruf, so Sieg Heil oder also Heil, Tonheil? Tonheil, Tonheil. Ja? Oder einfach Ciao. Ciao Sie. Eigentlich macht man es so, wie die Vietnamesen ohne Höflichkeitsfloskel einfach gehen. Man legt sich nur ein bisschen zu. Also, hau rein, ne? Tschüssi. Ciao!ige Mitarbeiter bei uns. Extrem unsympathisch, oder? Ja. Finde ich echt unangenehm. Du warst gerade dabei, deine tollen Geschichten aus dem Flugzeug zu sehen. Nein, es ist ja so, ich kann mir das richtig gut vorstellen, weil du bist ja ein Observational Comedy Genius, könnte man sagen. Ich glaube, die Spiegel.de hat... Meine Augen werden gerade so gross. Spiegel.de hat dich so bezeichnet, tatsächlich. Und ich kann mir mal vorstellen, dass alle anderen irgendwie genervt am Schalter stehen und sich betatschen lassen. Und während du nur so mit grossen Augen guckst, passiert was? Irgendwie, wo ist mein Stand-up-Bit, wo sind die drei Minuten, die ich hier rauseiern kann? Ja, wo sind die Tomatensaft bestellen und so? Kann ich dir den Keks haben? Diese ganzen Dinge, ich habe den Keks mitgebracht, ja, Keks. Die habe ich dir mitgebracht. Es gab zur Auswahl natürlich salzig oder süss und da ich natürlich das Falsche genommen habe und da habe ich es mitgebracht, den habe ich verpackt als Geschenk. Ja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Fliegen ist toll, ich hätte auch mit dem Zug fahren können, aber es ist mir einfach zu lame, weil Fliegen ist ein Abenteuer, Fliegen ist ein Ereignis, da redet man noch drüber im Podcast. Ja, wie gesagt, ich kann verstehen, warum man Flugangst hat, weil alleine diese Safety-Card vor dir ist schon auch so ein bisschen, du bist ja kontinuierlich damit konfrontiert, das was passieren könnte. Und du wirst die ganze Zeit darauf vorbereitet, die erste halbe Stunde im Flug, zehn Minuten, dass du möglicherweise stirbst und wie du damit umgehst, damit es nicht passiert. Du weißt aber, dass wahrscheinlich stirbst du, wenn du einfach runterfällst. Wärts wahrscheinlich. Und vor allem auch die Tatsache, dass Schwimmwesten an Bord sind. Ja. Da ich mir auch erstens so, okay, wir fliegen Berlin-Köln. Mhm. Why? Worauf genau, was habt ihr vor, ihr verrückte Mühner? Ich glaube, den Gag gibt es eins zu eins irgendwo so. Das ist so ein Gag, wo ich... Ist aber egal, aber ist egal, das sagen wir nicht mehr. Ab folgfünfzig sagen wir sowas nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das ist ein Mario-Bart-Gag, irgendwas so, dass man innerhalb binnländlich fliegt und dann eigentlich die Schwimmwässerung braucht. Ich werde mal gefragt, warum haben nicht alle Passagiere Fallschirme um? So, das heißt, wenn es dann irgendwie so zu einem Unglück kommt oder man merkt, dass irgendwer die Cockpit-Tür abgeschlossen hat, dass man einfach dann rausspringt und dann so 150 Menschen …
Einfach direkt in den Ozean und direkt ertrinken einfach.
Ja, ja, wieso ertrinken? Dafür haben wir die Schwimmwesten an Bord. Und einfach so, wenn so
150 Menschen mit so einem Fallschirm einfach so auf die Erde segeln. Das ist ein cooles Bild,
die Leute würden aufhören mit ihren Tätigkeiten und Fotos davon machen.
Gute Werbung. Man kann auf den Fallschirm Werbung anbringen.
Wow, Keks zum Beispiel, K-X, kann man aber keine Werbung machen, Podcast-Ufo-Werbung. Ja, aber das sind diese Dinge, die man sich dann überlegt, wenn man in Todesangst und sich eineinhalb Stunden vordermann klammert. Ist dir vor allem auch aufgefallen, dass diese Figuren, die dann gemalt sind auf diesen Safety-Cards nicht wirklich traurig gucken, dafür, dass sie gerade eine Safety-Position einnehmen müssen, dass ist das Strichmännchen, eigentlich alle grinsen immer noch. Das stimmt eigentlich, das ist falsch. So grinsen, so eine Person. Aber auf der anderen Seite würde ich wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig machen, wenn das aufgerissen, so horrorverschreckte Augen. Ja, einer ist ohnmächtig, hat sich schon erhängt irgendwie, der eine hat sich erschossen. Ist wahrscheinlich nicht so die Szenerie. Nee, aber es ist, glaube ich, weil man auch so besonders behandelt wird, auch dass man so eine Choreo bekommt am Anfang, ist einfach in der Comedy wahnsinnig breitgetreten worden schon einfach, weil so viele Sachen einfach anders sind, auch dass diese, wenn im Zweifelsfall diese Masken runterkommen, diese Luft, Sauerstoffmasken, dass man dann erst das selber machen soll, dass dann Kindern helfen soll. Ja genau, das hat so eine Jack Bauer-Mannität. Also ob man Menschen daran erinnern müsste, dass es egoistische Arschläger sind. Ja, danke, da bin ich auch drauf gekommen. Geil. Das ist echt ganz schön, ganz schön lustig. Ich finde es immer noch erstaunlich, dass es Leute gibt, die in Flugzeugen sitzen und nicht konstant komplett fasziniert sind, dass sie gerade in einem riesigen Stahlwurm sich durch die Luft bewegen. Ja, das ist echt krass. Ich schaue aus dem Fenster und gucke die Leute an so, wo, wo, wo, what the fuck. Und ich sitze da auch immer so, ich gucke mal aus dem Fenster mit so einem Blick. Das ist wie wenn so eine Katze vor dem Fenster sitzt und da landet ein Vogel kurz vorm Fenster und die Katze guckt dich an so, hallo, siehst du das auch gerade? Sorry, sorry, hallo, hallo, warum regierst du denn nicht? Ja, und so sitze ich auch immer im Flugzeug und denke auch jedes Mal auf der Startbahn denke ich mir, ne, die Flügel sind zu klein, wir sind viel zu schwer.
Auf dem Hinflug, da bin ich später gelandet, das heißt, da wird ja in der Kabine das Licht ausgemacht, damit der Pilot alles sehen kann und so, da wird das Kabinenlicht gedimmt, wenn man in der Nacht landet. Und hinter mir musste die Frau natürlich das Licht anmachen, um ihre Intouch weiterzuleszulesen, während man landet. Aus der Luft, wie ein anmutiger Vogel landet man auf der Landebahn, die dafür vorgesehen ist. Und es ist so eine technische Meisterleistung eines Menschen und sie liest ihre In-Touch weiter. Das kannst du auch zu Hause. Aber warum willst du dieses Miracle der Menschheit nicht erleben? Das verstehe ich dann aber nicht. Aber das, worauf ich mich am meisten vorbereite, ist, wenn ich mal Kinder habe, dann will ich den Kindern immer alles erklären können. Weil ich finde, es gibt keine unangenehmere Situation, als wenn du in der Bahn sitzt und das Kind fragt so, Papa, warum ist der Himmel blau? Und der gesamte Abteil schaut auf den Vater so, ja, erklär mal, warum ist eigentlich der fucking Himmel blau? Sie legen alle ihre Wissenschafts-, ihre Meteorologie-Prospekte beiseite. Ja, alle so unauffällig, so ihre Kopfe heraus, so, ja, erzähl mal. Ja, mein Schatz, weil, na ja, weißt du, Licht besteht aus vielen Farben. Gelb und grün, er gibt blau. Dann bricht sich, und das kannst du ja nicht erklären. Deswegen überlege ich mir immer, wie würde ich jetzt gerade einem Kind erklären, dass wir gerade fliegen, wie funktioniert das? Magnete. Siehst du diese weissen Dinger im Himmel, das sind Magnete. Oder mit den Augen, so einfach ganz streng angucken und versuche mit den Augen zu erklären, dass es selbstverständlich ist. Und dann so ausholen auch vielleicht und so ein bisschen zum Schlag ausholen.
Einfach es zum Schweigen bringen, dass sich solche Fragen nicht stellt in der Öffentlichkeit.
Ist es nicht einfacher, ein stummes Kind zu haben?
Aber man wünscht sich ja viele Behinderungen nicht als Elternteil.
Also es gibt ja aber so stumme Kinder.
Man erspart sich, glaube ich, viel, weil Kinder sind ja auch wahnsinnig ehrlich in der Öffentlichkeit.
Ich habe heute ein Gespräch mit dem Vater geführt und habe ihn gefragt, was ist unangenehmer, seine Kinder beim Masturbieren zu erwischen oder von seinen Eltern beim Masturbieren erwischt zu werden. Was ist unangenehmer? Und da hat er auch als Argument angebringtes Problem, ist nicht die Situation selbst, sondern dass Kinder alles erzählen im Nachhinein. Und wenn sie, sowohl wenn sie erwischt worden wären, als auch wenn sie den Vater erwischen beim Masturbieren, erzählen sie das am nächsten Tag in der Schule allen, weil dann ist immer so, ja, was habt ihr gestern erlebt und ja, ich bin bei meinem Papa ins Zimmer gegangen und dann hat er sich da irgendeine Blumenwiesen angeguckt und so und dann Schuhe poliert, genau, hat er mit seinem Kaninchen gespielt und so. Kinder verwenden auch konstant solche Euphemismen, die ganze Zeit über zu reden. Deswegen ist es unangenehmer. Wurdest du mal beim Masturbieren erwischt? Ich glaube nicht. Ich auch nicht tatsächlich. Ich glaube nicht. Aber wahrscheinlich schon, oder? Also ich meine, wir müssen uns... Die Eltern wissen das ja. Merkt das doch. Eltern wissen das doch auch. Eltern sind ja auch nicht anders. Die spüren das, meinst du? Die haben so ein Gefühl, so eine Telefaktie. Die Mutter auch verarbeitet. Moment. Moment mal. Stefan. Ach, scheiße. Ach Gott. Ja, aber München ist eben, ich war noch nie in München und du kommst ja aus München. Ich komme aus Minga. Und ich dachte, Minga. Ja, sicher. Und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, hier war Florentin in deiner Jugend. Hier, diese Straße, das ist ja schon mal lang gelaufen. Genau, da ist er hoch und runter gehopst mit seinem grossen Rad. Nee, aber das fand ich total erstaunlich. Also bist du da, du bist ja in der Nebenstadt von München aufgewachsen, aber wie oft warst du in München? Sehr, sehr oft. War schon so die Hauptstadt für dich als Kind? Recht oft, ich bin früher mit meinem besten Freund immer nach München gefahren, dann durften wir einkaufen und so. Wir sind dann alleine durch München gelaufen, waren wir bei McDonalds und so, das war dann alles toll. Es ist ja schon eine sehr schöne Stadt, man geht da sehr gerne durch und ich habe mich jetzt natürlich, weil ich auch Thuri war, so ein bisschen auch gefühlt wie einfach wie Urlaub halt. Weil es dann einfach so eine Stadt ist, für die man in den Urlaub fährt, weil überall sind Denkmäler, überall sind Zeitziegenbusse rum. Wie fühlt man sich dann, wenn man in Köln wohnt? Sehr, sehr schlecht tatsächlich. Ja, ohne Scheiss. Vor allem in München tatsächlich, das muss ich auch sagen, was einem auffällt, ist, die Menschen da sind sehr schön. Einfach, ich finde, wenn man da hinkommt, fällt mir das immer wirklich konkret auf, so okay, hier sind sehr viele, sehr schöne Menschen. Einfach weil da viele reiche Menschen sind und, muss man jetzt auch mal sagen, ist vielleicht politisch nicht ganz korrekt, das sind halt nicht so viele Ausländer. Und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, hier bla, Toleranz und so, aber ich gehe da schon davon aus, dass die meisten Menschen sexuell zu den Menschen am meisten hingezogen sind, die sag ich mal, rassisch ähnlich ausgestattet sind tatsächlich. Natürlich gibt es da Ausnahmen und sowas in der Richtung, aber ich glaube, dass...
Perversionen.
Genau, Rassenschande nennt man das, aber ich glaube, dass es von der Mehrheit schon so ist
und dass eine homogene Menge an Menschen eher attraktiv wahrgenommen wird als eine...
So, das würden wir alles rausschneiden.
Alles klar, wuhu!
Genau, da ist mir die Maus ausgerutscht.
Wow, aktueller Anlass. Nicht schlecht. Geil. Man merkt, dass du plötzlich fulltime gearbeitet hast. Die ganzen Anspielungen versteht. Jenny, was Gags ist, einfach so Bild.de die ganze Nacht runtergescrollt. Du kennst die Gags. Ich kenne alles. Ich fand es wirklich echt interessant, wobei ich mit den Menschen nicht so ganz warm wurde. Also da war eine Eisverkäuferin und dann, willst du mich auch angucken? Wollen wir mit mir das? Wollen wir das mal ganz kurz nachspielen, diesen Dialog? Vor allem, weil es eine Eisverkäuferin ist, wo wir Erfahrung mit haben. Okay. Ja, ich hätte gerne einen Becher, zwei Kuh. Ja, servus, grüste, hol mir die Erde, wie geht's da? So sind Münchner nämlich genau nicht. Kölner werden so vielleicht. Aber Münchner, Münchner, Münchner, sind wir noch im Rollenspiel? Nein, ich brech aus direkt. Münchner sind so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen diese, diese Arroganz, die vielleicht von Österreich so ein bisschen hochkommt, diese Wiener Arroganz, von der man spricht, dieses, ähm, von der man immer spricht, von der ich pausenlos erzähle. Erste Date, Sabine, Toleranz. Das stimmt es echt, Stefan, wirklich, wenn du den nicht gut kennst, ständig, was ist denn los mit dir jedes Mal über, ja, in Wien, die Leute sind ja so arrogant, ich war doch noch nie in Wien, aber das hört man ja immer öfter, ne? Aber das ist so ein bisschen so eine Arroganz, die vielleicht auch gar nicht negativ gemeint ist oder so, aber sie kommt einfach so ein bisschen blöd rüber. Ja, kann sein. Ich mag dieses Thema nicht, dieses die Leute da sind so und so, dieses Lokalpatriotismus ist mir echt egal. Ist mir echt wirklich verliebt. Auch jetzt Karneval geht mir so dermaßen auf die Nerven, ist echt schrecklich, deswegen verlasse ich. Ich wurde eben von einem Ghostbuster gefragt, wo es denn zur Poststrasse geht. Who are you gonna call, Stefan Dietze? Den fragt ein Ghostbuster, wenn er nicht weiß, welche Uhren. Was anderes, ich war in München, da gibt es ja immer so ganz viele Kirchen, du bist ja auch römisch-katholisch, du kennst die Raketenkirchen aus, und da war ich in so einer, da gibt es so eine Gruft, also oben war halt dieser langweilige Kirchenteil, die man daoren 1728, ist gestorben 1729, mit dem exakt gleichen Namen, exakt gleiches Geschlecht. Was ist da los gewesen, bitte? Da ist offensichtlich ein Kind gestorben, dann zum Leben er war und Jahre später hat er noch mal gestorben. Wie ist das Kind Jesus? Ich glaube, es war ein bisschen so, wenn ein Kleinkind mit einem Hund gross wechseln, der stirbt, dann kauft man einfach einen neuen und hofft, dass es nicht erkennt, dass es irgendwie ein anderer Hund ist. Man kriegt auch den gleichen Namen. Und so war das mit dem, glaube ich, auch irgendwie. Es war so ein Adelsgeschlecht, die haben ein Kind bekommen, ist mit einem Jahr gestorben, da haben die schnell noch ein Kind bekommen und gehopft, okay, hoffentlich hat es niemand gemerkt, es war halt nur ein Jahr alt, und dann ist er aber nach einem Mal wieder gestorben und haben es einfach aufgegeben. Scheiße. Damals war die Nachrichtenlage auch nicht so krass, das hat er nicht mitbekommen, wenn so ein Kind stirbt, ne? Es ist wie König der Löwen, dass das Kind so hoch gehalten wird über dem Stephansdom. Ist der in München? Weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe nicht so viel Zeit. Du hast einfach jetzt mal Stephansdom gesagt, weil du Stefan heisst. Einfach kreatives Schreiben mit Stefan T. Ja, ich komme aus der Stadt Stephans Stadt. Ja, Stephans Stadt.
Ich heisse Stephan Stephanstadt. Das war schon ganz schön lustig. Was hast du so erlebt am Wochenende? Nicht viel. Was hast du gemacht am Wochenende? Ich war am Wochenende in Berlin. Echt jetzt? Ja, ich wohne immer noch halb in Berlin. Aber es ist nicht so spannend, lass uns lieber Magnete reden. Okay. Waete. Magnete. Heute unsere Magnete. Magnete. Heute Magnete. Einfach mal erklärt. Für Dummies, Magnete für Dummies. Die haben ja mit Magneten Unglaubliches geschafft, und zwar haben die erst mal erzeugt, denn die, irgendwer, die.
Da gab es ja so ein Riesen, da war auch bei Nine-Gag irgendwie so ein Thema, weil so eine Riesenmaschine gebaut wurde, die echt ein bisschen gruselig aussah, wo drin jetzt zum ersten Mal quasi eine Kernfusion stattfinden konnte, dass man halt in Zukunft alle Energieprobleme löst. Und das hat man mit Magneten geschafft und das war's, das war die Rubrik, das war der Update, der Magnet-Update mit Stefan, das Fun steht, I put the Fun in Magnete. Ja, naja, haben wir jetzt eigentlich die, die, die... Ich bin echt traurig, dass wir letzte Woche, dass wir einfach die Folge weg ist. Ja, es war eine Qualitätsfrage, man kann sich überlegen, soll man die halbgare Folge raushauen oder sollen wir jetzt nochmal eine gut klingende, aber inhaltlich schwache Folge machen? Was ist besser? Gut klingt, aber inhaltlich schwach oder andersrum? Gut klingt, aber inhaltlich schwach. Ja. Das William-Cone-Prinzip. Ja, und du fängst jetzt an, William Cone zu dissen oder was? Er ist nicht mehr da, jetzt können wir machen, was wir wollen. Ey, er ist nicht mehr nicht mehr da. Okay, warte mal. Gut klingen, aber kein Inhalt. Chappi. Die neue Sorten. Ich dachte, gibt es jetzt irgendeinen bestimmten Gag, der da passt? Stimmt. Ey, es tut mir echt leid, ich bin echt wahnsinnig müde gerade. Was ist denn was mit dir? Ich bin drei Tage... Du warst aber auch letztes Mal schon ein bisschen neben der Schule. Nee, nee, stimmt nicht. Aber ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass du dich ein bisschen veränderst. Also du hast jetzt irgendwie, neuer Lebensabschnitt ist gekommen, irgendwie Stefan Tingo mal wieder, nimmt dir das Zepter des eigenen Lebens in die Hand. Du schreibst ja gerade irgendwelche Studien, Geschichten und so und bist völlig durch den Wind. Nö. Besuchst irgendwelche Freunde, von denen ich persönlich noch nie gehört habe. Ja. Wo ich jetzt persönlich auch sagen würde, hm, klingt ausgedacht, Simon klingt ausgedacht. Simon klingt sehr ausgedacht, ja, du konntest noch nicht mal den Namen von einem sympathischen Tontypen merken, und jetzt kommt hier so ein Simon um die Ecke. Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll. Ne, ich vernehme mich nicht, ich bin einfach nur müde, weil ich den letzten drei Tage nicht so gut geschlafen habe. Warum hast du nicht geschlafen, ging es hoch her? Ui, ui, ui. Die Münchner Nächte sind legendär. Nee, wir waren einfach jeden Abend feiern, oh, bis in die Puppen. Ja, wo wart ihr? Haben wir in Berghain. Hä, in München? München, Minger, sagt man. Das war eine Funfrage jetzt. Nee, ernsthaft, wo wart ihr in München? Wir waren im Hofbräuhaus, wir haben die klassische Tour-Tour halt gemacht. Ich hör einfach auf, mit deinen Scheiss Augen zu rollen. Wenn du in der Kackstadt... Hab niemand mit den Augen gerollt. Aber das ist... Das war ein Herzinfarkt. Sorry, Florentin, stell wieder auf. Wir waren echt im Hofbräuhaus. Wir haben so die ersten ... Er hat mich dann direkt, nachdem ich gelandet bin, direkt ins Hofbräuhaus genommen und so einfach das ganze Pulver verschossen. Weil es war in München in der Nutshell, direkt einfach mit einem Brezel, einem Mass und dann hast du einfach ... Merk hat dem München auch da nicht mehr zu bieten. Ja. Es ist schön, aber das war dann auch vorbei. Da waren wir, da waren wir im Hardrock-Café tatsächlich. Aber es tut mir leid, aber wir waren da. Aber ganz kurz, wenn du mit solchen Leuten unterwegs bist, denkst du dir dann schon manchmal, ey, ich bin echt scheisse langweilig? Oder stehst du da komplett drüber? So langweilig bin ich nicht. Ich habe dir gerade erklärt, was man mit Neuem Magneten erreicht hat. So langweilig kann ich nie sein. Ich bin ja auch total langweilig, aber ich glaube, der Unterschied zwischen langweiligen und nicht langweiligen Leuten ist primär, dass sie sich das nicht denken. Oh mein Gott, bin ich langweilig. Naja, aber ich war ja nur zweckgebunden im Hardrock-Café, weil ich wollte wirklich den Superbowl gucken. Weil ich wollte halt Hardrock. Ich wollte wirklich, ich liebe Hardrock und dass es nur mal so ein Kackladen ist da, kann ich auch nichts für. Aber ich persönlich gehe da drin auf. Ne, ich wollte wirklich den Superbowl gucken, weil das ist wirklich ein Ereignis, was die Massen bewegt. Und ich finde auch du und ich, Leute, die mit dem Zeitgeschehen zu tun haben, die ihren Podcast machen, die Leuten was bieten sollen, wir müssen am Zeitgeschehen nahe daran wohnen. Was hat das eigentlich mit diesem neumodischen Trend auf sich, dass man sich hier plötzlich für amerikanische Sportarten interessiert? Weiß ich nicht. So Super Bowl und hier. Man ist für die amerikanische Serien. Es ist ja auch, die Unterhaltungsindustrie ist in Amerika einfach geil. Ein Sport ist ja auch Unterhaltung und das läuft auch cooler. Und das ist schon auch ein cooler Sport. Ja, aber den Sport versteht kein Mensch. Du tust ja auch nur so, als würdest du ihn verstehen. Naja, der Quarterback hat jetzt den... Ich hab letztlich genug Fachbegriffe, um so zu tun, als ich verstehe. Und dann Neodrin. Homerun! Homerun! Den Gag hat, glaube ich, gestern jeder gemacht. Naja. Gut! Aber das Geile war, dass wir da in so einem Hardrock-Kaffee waren und du hast die ganze Nacht, das geht ja wirklich sehr lange, das geht viel zu lang, du kriegst die ganze Nacht Burger und ich habe irgendwann um halb vier noch zwei Burger gegessen oder so und ich habe echt Angst, dass meine Vertrauung nie wieder normal wird. Dass du den Rest seines Lebens diesen Burger machen kannst. Es war halt so ein Ding, da werden immer Burger rauskommen, da war eine Küche und es kamen andauernd Frauen raus mit so Tabletten, mit Burgern. Das war wirklich wie so ein Himmelgeschenk einfach. Es war wahnsinnig, es war wie so, als wäre man im Paradies und dann plötzlich fing vor uns am Tisch einer einfach zu weinen. Ein Mann. Vor Glück. Da dachte ich mir, wie nah, wie nah sind eigentlich Tragik und der Himmel. Aber warum hat er geweint? Weiß ich bis heute nicht. Er hat geweint, die mussten zahlen und alle haben den Tisch verlassen. Und es war irgendwie die ersten zehn Minuten des Spiels. Und man ist da vorher schon vier Stunden und wartet darauf, dass es endlich anfängt. Und dann hat einer von denen plötzlich geweint. Es ist so ein Mythos, der da irgendwie entstanden ist. Und alle haben dann irgendwie immer auf diesen leeren Tisch gestarrt, der da irgendwie so verloren in dem Raum stand, wo doch die getrockneten Tränen... Auf dem Trink geht noch, ja. Hast du auch geweint an dem Abend? Aber aus Glück, ja, ja. Also wenn immer Bürger kommen, von von... Hast du schon mal wirklich aus Glück geweint? Ah, das ist nicht schlecht, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als Kind habe ich mal an Weihnachten, da habe ich von so einer Tante oder so, von Leuten, wo man immer denkt, ja komm, das ist mir scheissegal, was du mir schenkst, irgendein Buch, weil ich irgendwie mal vor acht Jahren erwähnt habe, ich mag irgendwie Eidechsen, kriege ich jetzt ununterbrochen Eidechsenbücher über irgendwelche spannenden Eidechsenabenteuer, die mich in Scheisse interessieren, aber das sagt man ja auch zu Tante nicht. Und dann hat die mir geschenkt, und da war ich echt noch recht jung und hat mir geschenkt, ein Fotoapparat. Ja. Und das fand ich so geil, dass ich meinen eigenen Fotoapparat habe, dass ich geweint habe.
Und sie so, oh ja, Entschuldigung, tut mir leid, ich kann dir was anderes besorgen. Ach so. Und ich war wirklich so in Tränen, dass ich nicht mehr antworten konnte. Ich so, nein, nein, nein, nein. Und in der Seite hat sie schon weggeschmissen in den Fotoapparat, schon das Eidex-Buch wieder reingeschleppt, das Backup geschenkt gebracht. Ja, genau. Das Playmobil-Auto ja schon wieder ran. Nein, wir schmeißen es direkt weg, du musst nicht... Nein!
Und dann wurden die Freudenstränen so trauern. Und niemand wusste mehr was.
Ich konnte mich einfach nicht ausdrücken.
Und dann Talking Head von Floridins Eltern. Seitdem war ich ein anderer Mensch.
Ja.
Und das war echt grossartig, als ich diesen Fotoapparat hatte.
Dann war ich immer im Urlaub und meine Mutter hat im Nachhinein eine Collage gemacht von den ganzen Fotos, die ich im Urlaub gemacht habe, weil man nicht auf den Fotos nichts erkennen kann, weil ich grösst als einfach mehr oder weniger in die Sonne direkt fotografiert habe und es einfach nur so abstrakte Formen. Einfach weil es kann, einfach weil es kann. Hat es mal jemand gemacht und die Sonne fotografiert? Nein! Und ich stelle mir einfach nur so vor, wie ich in ein paar Jahren so meinen Kindern mit so einem Fotoalbum auf den Schoss so, ja, und da war ich in Paris und einfach so dreimal drei Bilder, die einfach komplett rot sind, weil einfach nichts ist und dann, das war am Louvre, ja hier, tatsächlich.
Ja, das gute alte Fotoalbum stimmt auch aus, ne, in zehn Jahren zeigt man dann seinen Kindern den Instagram-Account, das ist auch was anderes.
Das glaube ich auch, tatsächlich.
Wobei, es könnte natürlich so ein alternativer Instagram-Account sein, wo man denkt, du könntest nachher Farbe sortieren und dann wird so von Weiss nach Grau und niemand weiss, was du wirklich Motive fotografieren wolltest. Also du denkst, es wäre so ein Kunstprojekt, du wolltest Farben abbilden. Ja, aber das sieht so aus wie ein grosses Bild, dass jedes Bild so ein Pixel ist, sodass du am Ende so ein Lebensbild hast. Am Ende hast du einfach ein grosses Weiss. So ein riesiges Hakenkreuz, so was, warum das denn? Wie konnte das denn passieren? Unterbewusstsein, ja, aber das könnte man, Sag mal, es ist zum siebten Mal dein Hedge, scheiß Handy auch runtergefallen. Ich lege es dir hin, ich weiss nicht, wie das passieren konnte. Aber wir sind jetzt zum Glück in einem Tonstudio, wo ja alles mit Schaum ausgekleidet ist, um den Ton zu schlucken. Deswegen ist mir auch egal. Deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht darüber nachgedacht, ich sollte vielleicht das verändern, dass es mir Handy nicht normal runterfällt, weil es passiert nichts. Das kann nicht passieren. Ja, das ist wie eine Hüpfburg, hier ist alles weich, um den Ton zu schlucken. Ich habe es schon wieder gleich hingelegtlegt, wo es eben dreimal runtergefallen ist, weil es mir einfach... Du hast aber auch, man muss mal ganz kurz Stephans Körperhaltung beschreiben, also es ist ja wirklich fast liegend, fast komatös, liegt er da in seinem Rücklängs, ich sehe ihn auch kaum noch, sein Gesicht komplett gegen die Decke gerichtet, hat er wie so eine riesige Eistüte sein Mikrofon in der Hand, leckt er auch ab und zu dran und redet da so grob in die Richtung, Ansonsten ist es eine komplette Körperentspannung. In der linken Hand hat er sein Mikrofon, die rechte Hand hängt einfach komplett runter. Mit dem Handy habe ich eine Hand, wo einfach manchmal so Tinder nebenbei checke. Hose ist offen, Gürtel hat schon lange nicht mehr diese Hose gesehen. Also du bist wirklich ein anderer Mensch geworden. Ich finde das faszinierend, da so Stück für Stück zuzugucken, wie du dich veränderst. Sagt der, mit dem ich neulich im Kino war, der eine Jogginghose anhatte. Ja. Ich dachte, für dich ist Kino so ein Event. So, man geht irgendwo hin und dann ist eine Abendveranstaltung, wir hatten Love Seat, kann man mal jetzt sagen hier offensichtlich. Ja, aber auch geiler. Was auch geil war, weil du sagst ja, wir haben übrigens Love Seat, ich dachte mir, ja. Vorhin kriegt man manchmal Gags, wenn man vorher den Abend plant und so. Das war das erste Mal, dass wir was zusammen unternommen haben. Und tatsächlich haben wir ein Love-Seed, wir hatten wirklich ein Love-Seed. Und du eine Jonghy-Hose natürlich an. Ja klar. Okay, was hat er heute noch vor? Und wenn du glaubst, dass ich eine Unterhose anhatte, dann hast du das aber völlig falsch interpretiert. Aber ich finde, es ist erstens eine sehr interessante Diskussion zum Thema Respekt. Vor dem Medium habe ich schon oft geführt, weil ich auch oft ins Theater gegangen bin früher und die dann mal alle Anzug an hatten und so und ich dachte mir, fuck it, ich gehe da mit kurzer Hose rein, weil ich finde nicht, dass die Kleiderordnung notwendigerweise was mit Respekt zu tun hat, sondern eher sowas wie, redet man während der Aufführung, wie lange bleibt man sitzen, wie halten man sich an der Applausordnung und sowas in die Richtung. Ich würde diese Meinung nicht mehr hundertprozentig unterschreiben, vielleicht, ich würde nicht mehr mit Jong in Hose ins Theater gehen und so, aber Kino finde ich wirklich, ist okay. Aber da finde ich es dann besser, also habe ich lieber als den Typ, der dann im Anzug da ist und dann die ganze Zeit irgendwie laut ist oder am Handy telefoniert, als den Typ in Jogginghose, der das Medium so respektiert. Das ist ja bei, wo wir dann wieder beim Flugzeug wären, es war damals ja auch mal echt ein Ereignis zu fliegen, Leute haben sich wirklich schick gemacht, haben sich so schöne Hüte aufgesetztgesetzt und dann reisen so ein Ding und haben sich ihr Jackett gehabt und so. Und dann, das passt ja dann auch irgendwie, weil jetzt ist gerade das Gefälle zwischen Stewardess und Mallorca-Klasse, die irgendwie noch halbbesoffener irgendwie im Gang liegt. Mit Badehose da rief und nicht mehr. Ja, auch mit diesem Sonnenschirm dann irgendwie nicht klarkommen mit dem Gepäckablage und dann kommen halt so die super gestylten, perfekt frisierten Stewardessen um die Ecke und das Gefälle ist einfach so groß, aber damals hat es einfach gepasst, damals war es einfach wahrscheinlich okay, weil die einfach auch gut angezogen waren, die Leute. Ja, komisch, glaubst du, dieser oberflächliche Respekt verschwindet so langsam, dass man sich für gewisse Anlässe fein anzieht, sowas in der Richtung? Ja, offensichtlich. Aber warum? Ich meine, wird die Gesellschaft nicht immer oberflächlicher, aber warum verschwindet dann sowas? Ich glaube nicht, dass die Gesellschaft immer oberflächlicher wird. Ich denke, das ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall. Aha. Ich glaube, möchte ich auch nicht begründen jetzt. Ich möchte mich aber das These im Raum lassen. Nee, es ist doch so, dass immer, ich meine, guck dir mal diese ganze Hipster-Bewegung an, das ist ja jetzt nichts Ästhetisches oder doch. Also es ist doch einfach so ein, der Bart, also es ist doch, Bart ist jetzt auch nichts, es ist doch einfach um was zu verstecken, um Doppelkind zu verstecken oder um irgendwie das Hakenkreuz dazu, was man hat, irgendwie unsichtbar zu machen. Ja, so ein Milchbart, wenn man sich angekleckert hat, kann man gut verstecken. Ja, das ist einfach so was, man lässt sich einfach gehen so ein bisschen, ist Bart doch eigentlich. Nee, aber Hipster ist genau das Gegenteil von sich gehen lassen. Das soll ja so aussehen, als würde man sich gehen lassen, aber es ist alles genau durchstrukturiert. Zurück zum Love Seed. Tatsächlich, weil da habe ich das erste Mal tatsächlich, habe ich mich auch selbst verletzt in dem Moment, weil ich habe mir die perfekten Tickets gebucht, die perfekten Plätze im Kino reserviert, konnte dann aber ich nicht zahlen, weil ich kein Geld mehr hatte, weil ich pleite bin nebenbei und musste dann den Bestellvorgang nochmal neu... Spenden an, der verfolgt die Zelt. Da musste ich tatsächlich nochmal den Buchungsprozess von vorne starten und dann konnte ich die Plätze nicht mehr reservieren, weil die ja schon reserviert waren für mich, aber ich konnte sie nicht kaufen, deswegen musste ich den Love Seed daneben benutzen. Naja, aber die zerfallen ja nach fünf Minuten oder sowas. Nee, hatten sie nicht, komischerweise, die waren einfach eingeloggt. Das habe ich dir auch schon mal erzählt, ich, ähm, davor, nämlich das mal, als ich im Kino war, ä ich Plätze reserviert und dann hat man diese fünf Minuten, die so runterlaufen wie so ein Countdown, so du musst in fünf Minuten entscheiden, weil dann sind die Plätze weg, sonst kriegst du die nicht mehr. Und dann plötzlich hat sich, während die fünf Minuten aber noch dran waren, mein Bildschirm wurde schwarz, kam wieder und die Plätze waren weg. Und dann sagte ich mir, nein, ich habe diese fünf Minuten jetzt für mich gehabt, ich habe diese Plätze für fünf Minuten gehabt, auch wenn ich die nie kaufen wollte, weil ich einfach das Gefühl gehalten war, diese Plätze zu haben. Für einen kurzen, wunderschönen Moment im Universum waren diese Stimme ein. Nur wir drei waren da, diese zwei Plätze und ich waren da im Universum. Und dann plötzlich kam irgendwer und hat die einfach weggenommen. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie kann das sein, dass mir jemand in diesen fünf Minuten sich in mein System hackt und diese Plätze, also in dieses Bewusstsein, dass ich jemand für für zwei Kinositze in meinem PC hackt, da habe ich wirklich sauer auf diese Person. Und dann habe ich dann eine Frau daneben mir, genau auf diesen Plätzen, die ich vorher hatte, ich habe mich ein bisschen weiter rechts gesetzt, dann zwangsläufig, dann habe ich die Frau gefragt im Kino, wie sie das gemacht hat. Und wie hat sie das gemacht? Und die Auflösung? Fahr den nächsten Mal.
Clever, clever.
Ja, aber du kannst dich so einen Cliffhanger aufbauen und erwarten, dass ich irgendwie weitermache, mich mit großen Augen anschauen. Du kannst dir diese scheisse Handgeste, immer dieses Mach weiter, keine Ahnung, was du dir dramaturgisch ausgedacht hast hier in der Sache tatsächlich. Na, ich wollte es wirklich einfach offen lassen jetzt. Aber gibt's was frustrierenderes als die Auswahl bei den Tickets, die ja immer schon auf zwei Personen steht bei Default, nochmal anzuklicken und auf eins zu setzen? Ist das nicht der traurigste Moment, den es gibt? Einfach dieses, wir gehen davon aus, dass niemand allein ins Kino geht, deswegen haben wir die zwei und du nochmal klick. Sind sie sicher, dass sie einen? Das ist furchtbar, ne? Ah, das ist wirklich unangehoben. Dann gehst du und dann so, ah ja, einmal für Chappie nochmal. Die waren letzte Woche schon hier. Ja. Aber trotzdem zwei Tüten Popcorn. Ja, genau. Und die Nachos. Ja. Das ist echt hart, wenn man das schon weiss, aber irgendwas, eine Geste, die man noch machen muss, aktiv, das nochmal genau untermauert, was alles falsch läuft in deinem Leben.
Ja, das ist genauso, wie wenn du zum Beispiel ein Mac-Menü bestellst.
Früher gab es nämlich das Mac-Menü, so nämlich die Wandlung, wie fucking McDonald's uns abzockt.
Früher gab es das normale Mac-Menü und das konntest du upgraden zu dem grossen Mac-Menü mit grosser Pommes und grossem Getränk.
Heute ist es bei Default das grosse und wenn du die mittlere haben haben willst, dann musst du das McMenü Small bestellen tatsächlich. Und das war auch immer so ein Moment damals, doch ist so, und das war auch nämlich so ein Moment damals, wenn du sagst, McMenü mit grosser Pommes. Das war dann auch so für die Fetten oder die Extrafetten sozusagen. Deswegen ist es ganz nett von McDonalds, dass sie einem das abnehmen und einfach direkt davon ausgehen, dass du irgendwie mit deinen Arterien schon abgeschlossen hast und einfach sagst, ne, ich nehme einfach immer das Grosse. Ja, genau wie der Jumbo-Döner. Also ich werde von einem Döner nicht satt und dann bestelle ich mir einen Jumbo-Döner. Der heisst bei mir, bei meiner Imbissbude allerdings ums Eck, heisst ich tatsächlich, heisst der Jumbo-Döner XL. Und das traue ich mich dann nicht. Fetty McFatterson. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich hätte gerne einen Jumbo Döner. Und dann haben sie den Jumbo Döner XL. Und die Blonat dann auch immer noch so. Die wollen den richtig grossen? Sie wollen den Jumbo Döner XL haben, das ist ein halbes Fladenbrot. Ja. Ja, den wollte ich nehmen. Sie alleine, oder gehört die junge Dame da neben ihn auch dazu? Nee. Nee Nee, das ist ein... Und ich glaube auch, dass sie sich danach auf Türkisch über mich lustig gemacht haben. Ich weiß nicht, was das heißt. Man weiß es nicht. Wollen wir mal nochmal irgendwann Gäste haben eigentlich? Ja, ich würde... Ich weiß nicht, ob du schon so weit bist, aber früher oder später würde ich gerne... Ich würde gerne mal wieder andere Menschen sehen. Ich würde mit dir noch einen Gast haben, tatsächlich. Sollen wir mal ein bisschen Brainstorm, oder wollen wir mal die Community nochmal, obwohl da kamen echt furchtbare Vorschläge letztes Mal, ne? Ich fand Donny ganz gut, wir können Donny nochmal einladen. Lass uns Donny nochmal einladen. Aber unter dem Pseudonym. Wir verraten den Leuten nicht, dass Donny ist und nennen ihn irgendwie die ganze Zeit. Wir nennen ihn Tom. Ja. Wie fandest du Tom als Gast? Supergeil. Das ist supergeil. Hat abgeliefert. Ich finde es einen geilen Moment. Ich finde es einen geilen Moment, man erwartet das nicht. Der Moment war gut, ja. Man hört zwei Menschen reden, die man schätzen gelernt hat für das, was sie machen, und plötzlich kommt jemand in den Raum und die beiden schaffen es meisterhaft, wie ich finde, den einzubinden, das Gespräch und gar nicht irgendwie künstlich das Gespräch mit ihm aufrechtzuerhalten. Überhaupt nicht, ohne es im Nachhinein auszuschneiden. Genau, und es im Nachhinein rauszuschneiden und danach aber nochmal drüber zu reden, obwohl die Geschichte gar nicht drin vorkommt.
Und das dann nochmal von der vorletzten Folge nochmal einbauen, einfach ein bisschen klar zu kommen.
Aber es ist sauwindig, ne?
Es ist extrem windig dafür, dass wir in einem Turnstudio sind, es ist ungewöhnlich windig.
Und der Flug war auch extrem ruppig.
Ruppig?
Ne, und es war wirklich so, dass der Pilot wirklich auch vorgewandt hat, dass die Landung echt saumässig gefährlich wird. Das war nicht sein Wortlaut. Wort für Wort. Ey, Leute. Wow, ich weiß nicht, hier blinkt alles. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist. Gerade ist der Scheibwisch angegangen, Leute. Ich kann nicht dafür nichts mehr. Jeff, was ist das Rote da? What the fuck ist das? Nein, nein. Das ist genau das Schönste. Ich war ja in der Schule im Kochkurs. Oh Gott, hey! Ja, tatsächlich. How to start stories. How to lower expectations to a minimum and still disappoint. For dummies, Episode one of twenty. Und tatsächlich, ich war so schlecht in diesem Kochkurs, dass ich dreimal den Anfängerkurs machen müsste, weil alle dann immer so, ja und jetzt machen wir, jetzt könnt ihr euch entscheiden, wollt ihr asiatisches kochen, Hausmannskost oder wollt ihr irgendwie nochmal Fisch oder was Besonderes, da gab es dann so weitere Advanced-Kurse und Florentin, du kannst ja vielleicht wieder in den Anfängerkurs kochen. Du machst erstmal wieder Rührei, bleib dabei. Hast du da gelernt, machst du das heute noch, was du da gelernt hast? Ähm? Ja, tatsächlich, ich kann ja nur zwei Sachen kochen. Spaghetti Carbonara und Biskuitrolle. Und die kann ich aber wie ein junger Gott. Grossartig. Und Süsskartoffelsuppe. Meinst du machst auch beides gleichzeitig? Ja, genau, tatsächlich. Oder machst du Spaghetti Carbonara in Form einer Biskuitrolle? In die Fladenrolle, ja, als Füllung. Ist auch nicht schlecht, tatsächlich. Biskuit Carbonara. Mit Biskuit kann man wahnsinnig viel machen. Die Leute denken immer, oh, Biskuit ist so eine... Ich weiß gar gar nicht genau, was das ist eigentlich. Biskuit ist sehr viel Rollen. Ja, eine Rolle halt. Sehr viel Hass. Was? Hast du gesagt, was ist Biskuit, sehr viel? Sehr viel Hass. Tränen und Rache ist in Biskuit, ja. Mit Hass erschaffen. Viel Ei, aufgeschlagenes Eiweiss, aufgeschlagenes Ei und dann unterheben. Das ist ganz wichtig, dass es nicht einfach nur verrührt wird, sondern unterheben, wo mir bis jetzt noch niemand den Unterschied erklären kann. You got me at unterheben. Cool, man hat neue Brötter auch dazu. Auf jeden Fall tatsächlich hieß es dann irgendwann mal, ja, wir haben jetzt bald die Philologenkonferenz in der Schule und da hatten wir uns überlegt, dass vielleicht der Kochkurs, das so kleine... Wir brauchen Spaghetti Carbonara oder bis gut rollen. Und mit Kamerazoom, letzte Reihe hinten links, Snickers im Mund, steht langsam auf. You came to the wrong lizard, motherfucker. Also, ich hab Zeit. Ich hab noch nichts mehr. Wie ist der Zoom auf Florentin? Kann ich aufs Klo? Er hat was ganz anderes, er hat gar nicht mitbekommen, wo man was geht. Und dann sollten wir so Häppchen vorbereiten. Und dann haben halt die letzte Reihe die Idioten wieder, ja, scheiss drauf, warum nicht, haben das es geht. Und dann sollten wir so Häppchen vorbereiten und da haben halt die letzte Reihe die Idioten wieder, ja scheiss drauf, warum nicht, haben das halt gemacht und dann hatten wir, da war tatsächlich in so einem Klassenzimmer neben dem grossen Konferenzraum der Lehrer, wo dann halt irgendwie von der Landesregierung dann halt irgendwie so Kultusleute kamen und sich besprochen haben zu irgendeinem Scheiss und wir sollten das halt über dich, Krisen gesparen, genau, was los mit ihm? Und dann sollten wir halt so ... Also Bayern riecht nach Biskuit. Dann sollten wir halt so Häppchen vorbereiten und dann halt so in grossen Tabletts dann in den Pausen dahin und dann durch die Reihen laufen. Mit so einem Hut oder so? Auch so Koch-Koch-Style? Nee, gar nicht. Einfach, wir waren im Schüler-Outfit. Schüler-Outfit, ja tatsächlich. Also aber auch wenigstens so Motto-Scheiz irgendwie? Null, gar nicht. Cook me like you do oder weiss nicht jetzt, irgendwie sowas. Ja. The Cook of Silence, mein, ja, Tim Cook, kennt ihr noch nicht, aber wird mein Wortgag sein. The Cooks, she's got the cook. Und auf jeden Fall waren wir natürlich einfach freche Typen und wir hatten uns dann überlegt, dass wir in diese Häppchen auch Nieten einbauen. Also dass wir so ein ganzes Blech von Häppchen machen und eins ist eine Niete. Also da ist dann irgendwie halt einfach was Falsches drin. Du hast dann halt zum Beispiel irgendwie so... Stein. Stein, ja, du hattest dann... Das ist ja keine Kapsel, einfach so aus Gag. Ja, du hast dann so Cherrytomaten und da hast du dann Frischkäse reingetan und in einen haben wir halt nicht Frischkäse, sondern halt dann Mayonnaise reingetan oder halt irgend sowas, was noch einigermaßen geht, aber halt so ein bisschen falsch ist. Bei manchen Sachen war es auch noch härter und so. Das ist geil, so Punk. Es geht auch noch, aber es ist ein bisschen falsch. Das ist so die Gag-Ebene damals. Nicht ins Extreme, heute weißt du, man muss ins Extreme gehen, aber es ist so ein bisschen falsch. Ne, damit wir auch keine Probleme kriegen. So ein bisschen Verwirrung stiften. Ich glaube, ein paar haben wir auch komplett mit Butter gefüllt und so. Was war das Ziel? Wir sorgen für einen verwirrten Blick an den Abend, der aber auch nicht so verwirrt ist, dass er irgendwie mit Leuten spricht und einfach nur, er guckt einfach nur hoch. Ne, die Idee war, dass einer sagt so, das schmeckt halt ein bisschen komisch und dann alle so, ne, schmeckt wunderbar. Ja gut, dann muss es so. Und dann dem einen schmeckt und alle anderen hassen es. Das wäre geil. Ja, auch gut. Und dann haben wir halt einfach so ein paar Nieten eingebaut und haben uns halt kaputt gelacht die ganze Zeit. Und dann haben wir auch immer so von wegen, und dann haben wir halt nicht gemerkt, dadurch, dass es halt Sommer war. Nachher, weil so ein grosses X drauf war und die Z schutzig wurde. Wir waren halt im Klassenzimmer direkt neben diesem Konferenzraum und die Fenster waren alle offen, weil es halt Sommer war.
Und wir hatten halt immer so, Ihhh, weh, oh nee, oh alter, ey, wenn du das isst, kriegst du einen Euro, blä, ii, was halt die ganze Zeit, die ganze Zeit und dann irgendwann. Ja, und hier ist unser Kochkurs, der hat sich ein bisschen was überlegt, kleine Häppchen für die Pause von euch, Und dann kommen da so drei debil grinsende Idioten durch die Tür und so, ja, nehmt euch was, nehmt euch was, und alle so, nee, danke, ist so schon okay, der schlechteste Prank der Welt, oh Gott, das war auch, da haben wir zu spät gemerkt, aber das war auch so ein bisschen. Gar nicht schlecht, so auch bewusst keinen guten Gag machen, sondern so ein bisschen falsch. Ja, das ist die hohe Schule. Welche Dinge in deinem Leben machst du so ein bisschen falsch? Ich glaube, ich trinke ein bisschen zu wenig. Ich glaube, ich kogste ein bisschen zu viel. Das ist so krass, ich trinke ein bisschen zu wenig Flüssigkeit einfach. Ich nehme ein bisschen zu wenig. Ich habe nämlich gelesen, wenn man zu viel Wasser trinkt, kann man sterben. Also wenn du zu wenig trinkst, stirbst du, wenn du zu viel trinkst, stirbst du. Wir leben in einem kontinuierlichen Kampf gegen den Tod. Gegen das Wasser. Ist dir das klar? Gegen das Wasser. Wo wir denken, es ist doch das Coolste so hier auf dem Planeten, was uns am Leben hält. Nee, wir leben in so einer, also wir sind quasi wie so ein Pendel, was so auf zwei verschiedene Pole zurast. Ja. Das ganze Leben ist doch ein ewiges Hin und Her zwischen zu warm und zu kalt eigentlich. Ja, eigentlich schon. Hattest du schon mal so richtig das Gefühl, so, ja, jetzt ist richtig gute Temperatur gerade? Oder ist es immer ein bisschen zu kalt und ein bisschen zu warm? Aber wie ist es jetzt gerade im Moment? Es ist ein bisschen zu kalt, aber... Mir ist auch gerade ein Hauch zu kalt, nicht so, dass ich mich beschweren würde. Finde es cooler, wenn es cooler, wenn es zu kalt oder zu warm ist? Wie bitte? Bist es cooler, wenn es zu kalt oder zu warm ist? Zu kalt, ich bin ein absolut kalt Typ. Ich auch, deswegen fühle ich mich gerade echt wohl hier in diesem Raum. Ja. Es ist ein bisschen zu kalt, Schau. Also nicht so kalt, dass ich was ändern würde an der Situation, aber wenn ich es benennen müsste… Ich glaube, schreibt doch mal einfach in die Kommentare, ist es euch momentan ein bisschen zu kalt oder ein bisschen zu warm, oder habt ihr schon mal wirklich so… Aber schreibt es nur unter dieser Folge, ich habe Bock, in zehn Folgen noch diesen Gag irgendwann mal unter den Folgen zu lesen. Nee, aber ich glaube, man fühlt sich nie wirklich komplett wohl. Ich glaube, in dem Moment, ich glaube, das ist ja so diese buddhistische Weisheit, ne? In dem Moment, in dem du die Erlösung erreichst, verschwindest du. So, dann wirst du zum Geistwesen und sowas. Was ja im Umkehrschluss heisst, alle Menschen, die existieren, sind immer in gewisser Weise in Unbalance so ein bisschen. Da ist irgendwas falsch. Das ist wie beim Superbowl, als die ganzen Burger reinkamen, auch manchmal waren Leute verschwunden einfach. Einfach die Erlösung, weil die Satwa, einfach alle weg. Dann sind die Leute einfach weg, die waren erfüllt einfach. Es war perfekt, das Klima war perfekt, die Burger waren perfekt. Eigentlich ist ja alles gut bei uns. Ich meine, wir leben in einem Land, was gut Geld hat, wir haben einen Job, der einigermaßen das ist, was wir wollen. Und im Prinzip geht es uns so gut, dass wir, glaube ich, Dinge einfach erfinden, damit es uns nicht ganz perfekt geht. Ja. Weil sonst laufen wir rum in einer perfekten Welt, wo andere und Bürger reingebracht werden und wir wissen nicht genau, was wir machen sollen. Auch diese ganze Flüchtlingsnummer, ne, ist ja auch so, weil es war halt ein bisschen langweilig. Komm, lass uns die doch reinholen. Aber auch da habe ich mir gedacht, mit dieser ganzen Flüchtlingsdebatte, seit wann, also diese ganze besorgte Bürgerbewegung. Was heißt Topical Island? Warum nicht? Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Refugees welcome, Kar hast Angst. Und heute gehen die Leute auf die Strasse und sagen, wir haben ja nur Angst und so. Und man sagt, hallo, ihr habt Angst vor Flüchtlingen? Wir sind stolz, sagen zu dürfen, dass wir Angst haben. Was geht denn eigentlich mit euch ab? Die Flüchtlinge sind zum grössten Teil nicht giftig, sind schlecht ausgeschaltet. Wenn die sich alle als Zombies verkleidet hätten oder so. So was. Das würde ich verstehen, so Halloween. Warum sind die stolz darauf, Angst zu haben? Sind sie stolz darauf? Ja, das ist immer so Hauptsache. Ja, wir haben ja nur Angst, wir haben ja nur Angst. Ja, fickt euch! Bi-bi-bi-bi-bi, wir haben Angst vor Flüchtlingen. Ich habe echt ein bisschen Angst. Also, ohne Scheiss, die AfD liegt jetzt bei 13%, kann man sagen. 13%? Ich habe 13% gelesen. Ich habe 13% gelesen. Ich hoffe, wir gehen da eine, das ist nicht unsere Rubrik, glaube ich. Nee, aber lass mal... Wir müssen diemachen. Stimmt, die läuft ja dann immer. Ich mache mir echt ohne Scheiß ein bisschen Sorgen so. Wie hat das denn damals so angefangen im Dritten Reich? Da fiel doch auch irgendwann die Mitte an, so komisch rechts zu werden. Und ich glaube, wir leben ja auch noch in der Blase. Also wir leben ja mit Leuten umgeben, die ja alle vernünftige Bildung haben, vernünftige Leute sind. Ja. Und so würde ich mal behen, und die richtige Meinung haben. Aber ausserhalb dieser Blase ist es vielleicht noch krasser. Und wenn ich jetzt schon Angst habe, obwohl ich in meiner Blase lebe, dann haben wir vielleicht einfach echt ein Problem. Und dann sollten wir einfach auswandern. Hawaii. Dann soll ich was tun. Ja, macht er was. Ja, aber jetzt, genau, und da hat Top-Toppiker einen, wir schneiden was an, sollte was kommen, um zu unterfüttern, aber das kommt nicht mehr. Nee. Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne Single Ladys, all the single ladys. Apropos Super Bowl, Beyoncé hat die High-Up-Show unter anderem mitgemacht.
Ja, mit Coldplay, ne?
Und ich habe echt gehofft, dass sie Single Ladies singt.
Hat sie nicht.
Ich habe darauf, ich habe, ich habe dachte mir, ich gucke mir das heute an nochmal, ich finde es aber nicht so spannend, dass ich da jetzt mitfiebern würde, also wette ich mal.
Und dann habe ich Wetten abgeschlossen.
Wirklich, so richtig?
Sportwetten, ja. Nicht ganz Sportwetten, weil es gab so eine Fun-Section und da habe ich vier Euro darauf gewettet, dass Coldplays letzter Song Viva La Vida ist. Und es war erster Song, also es ist komplett daneben und ich war nicht so richtig sauer auf Coldplay und ein Kumpel von mir hat, wusste ich gar nicht, darauf gewettet, dass irgendwie so ein neuer Song von denen der erste Song ist. Das heißt, Coldplay hat unsere beiden Wünsche innerhalb von einem Takt Musik einfach komplett zerstört.
Wir waren beide so sauer und das finde ich geil. Die wollen Musik machen, die wollen unterhalten, das ist die Halftime-Show, die ist grossartig mit viel Püro und so. Und die Leute immer nur... Nein, nein, nein, Mann, fuck you, meine Hypothek, keine Streicher, keine Streicher, nein, mein Haus, das Saxophon, nein, fuck you! Meine Hypothek! Keine Streicher, keine Streicher, nein, man, Haus, das Saxophon! Nein, fuck you! Nein! Ist das ein Cis? Ist das ein Cis? Nein! Nein, meine Kinder! Aber ich glaube, da hast du es doch echt geschafft, oder? Wenn du so gross bist, dass Leute auf solchen Scheiss wetten, wo ich mir auch immer denken, warum geht nicht Chris Martin einfach hin, so letzter Song, wie will er wieder, ja, eine Million, machen wir, wette ich mit dir, das würde spielen. Aber du darfst halt nicht wetten, wenn du da... Ja, er macht halt seine Oma, so dann schickt er halt eine SMS, weil die fucking NSA dann diese eine SMS rauskriegt. Oder der, der die Setlist halt sieht vorher, weil er die ausdrucken muss. So ein Praktikant. Warum sind Praktikanten nicht Millionäre? Weil Praktikanten einfach dumm sind. Praktisch halt. Das ist das Problem. Also es war ganz cool. Hat dann die Haftabschau komplett zerstört für mich, weil ich die ganze Zeit so wütend das Ass. Gib mir noch einen Burger, Frau. Dann habe ich noch einen Burger genommen von dem Tablett. Aber das war schon ganz geil. Und ich habe auch noch Sportwetten abgeschlossen. Im dritten Viertel fallen die meisten Punkte und so. Und ich habe vier Wetten abgeschlossen und viermal habe ich exakt daneben gelegen. Aber genau, das war nicht einmal knapp, das war einmal komplett daneben. Und im Endeffekt habe ich jetzt zehn Euro verloren. Das ist nicht viel, aber trotzdem war ich ein bisschen sauer. Ja, ich hatte meine Phase, ich habe mal Lotto gespielt, tatsächlich vor zwei Monaten erst, weil ich hatte eine Phase, wo ich so viel Glück hatte, wo mir im Alltag so viele Dinge passiert sind, wo ich Glück hatte, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt muss ich was draus machen, jetzt muss was passieren. Das ist gerade wie ein Film, wo der Held gerade merkt, man könnte sich einen Film vorstellen, so ein normaler Typ lebt sein Leben und merkt, dass er plötzlich extrem viel Glück hat.
Ich würde es dann so weiterspinnen, so er merkt, dass es irgendwie ein Fehler in der matrix ist und die realität gar nicht echt ist und irgendwie solche sachen und sich dinge wiederholen die eigentlich die ball ist in der blauen pill oder roten pill genau so was in der richtung da bricht irgendwie die die realität zusammen und er klettert dann aus so einem riss in eine andere dimension für die realität in einem eisberg genau aber da zum beispiel der anfang also act break könnte da sein er spielt lotto und merkt, er gewinnt jedes Mal so und dann kann er da erstmal total das ausnutzen. Aber das ist auch cool, wie andere Leute darauf reagieren, wenn einer die ganze Zeit gewinnt, wenn einer die ganze Zeit im Lotto gewinnt. Ja genau, es wäre interessant, weil da würde alles zusammenbringen und er würde immer so weiter ausnutzen, dass er Glück hat und dann kommt ja so der Punkt so, dann gewinnt der Held erst ganz viel, aber dann muss er dafür zahlen, dass dann wegen ihm die Realität zusammenbricht und die Matrix kaputt geht, weil alle Leute merken, okay, hier stimmt was nicht. So, und da habe ich Lotto gespielt, tatsächlich, weil mir einfach Dinge passiert sind, die so nicht passieren dürfen. Weil dann Drehbuchideen nicht mehr von der Realität trennen konnten. Weil so in so einer Scheinwelt geht. Genau, da habe ich so einen Roboter kennengelernt, in den habe ich mich verliebt tatsächlich, der wurde aber wieder zerstört und in der nevadischen Wüste vergraben, dann musste ich nach Nevada und ja, den Rest glaube ich, könnt ihr alle auf Folge 31 nachhören. Der Rest ist Geschichte. Und der war tatsächlich, da hatte ich extrem viel Glück und da dachte ich mir, scheiße, ich muss jetzt aussitzen, habe Lotto gespielt, komplett verloren natürlich, habe aber jetzt tatsächlich noch 10 Euro Guthaben, weil ich glaube, man musste 20 Euro Guthaben und einmal kostet 10, ich habe noch was, wenn ich mal irgendwie dann wieder Glück habe, wenn mir viele gute Dinge passieren und viele gute Zufälle, dann spiel ich nochmal Lotto. Da muss es sein. Obwohl die Frage ist, dass er auch diese … Ich glaube auch, Gott ist nicht so ein Typ, der sagt, also du hast ganz viel Glück, oh, er merkt, dass er ganz viel Glück hat, jetzt spielt er Lotto, na. Na, so leicht machen wir es dann noch nicht mehr. Gott ist eine wiese Bank, er merkt, dass also er kriegt mehr als du. Also, und das System, Gott würde zusammenbrechen. The Gospel by Stephan Titzel. Gott ist wie eine Bank. Er nimmt immer mehr als du. Okay. Gott nimmt mehr als er bekommt. Amen. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich wie dieses Kopf oder Zahl, wie diese Zufallswahrscheinlichkeiten. Da kannst du auch drauf wetten. Der. Aber
die Frage ist, wenn du an einem Tag
viel Glück hast, hast du dann
am nächsten Tag mehr Glück,
weniger Glück oder gleich viel Glück?
Es ist ja genauso, wie wenn du eine
Münze wirfst und es ist Kopf
und du wirfst nochmal, ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit
höher, dass du Kopf hast oder
Zahl. Es ist Roulette,
Schwarz, Rot Prinzip. Natürlich,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer gleich, aber
rein intuitiv sagst du, ich habe
... höher, dass du Kopf hast oder noch mal oder zahlen. Es ist Roulette, Schwarz, Rot Prinzip und natürlich, es ist immer die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer gleich, aber rein intuitiv sagst du, ich habe schon dreimal Kopf in Folge geschnippt, jetzt muss doch schon langsam mal wieder zahlen. Deswegen gibt es ja dieses, habe ich schon mal erzählt, diesen grossartigen Logarithmus, du musst einfach nur ein Euro dieses Verdoppelungshacken. Genau, also du musst einfach verdoppeln, weil dann, wenn du dann immer mal gewinnst, dann hast du das, dadurch, dass du das immer verdoppelt hast, reingeholt, was du da vor der ganze Zeit verloren hast. So habe ich auch mal Geld verloren, Online-Casino. So habe ich mal 10 Euro verloren, ja. Ich glaube, irgendwie 14 oder so was. So haben alle Leute ihr Geld verloren, weil das einfach mal irgendwie eine Lüge in die Welt gesetzt hat. Ja. Gott. Aber sogar Einstein, wir hatten heute einen Hörer, der Einstein beleidigt hat, möchte ich an der Stelle mal ganz kurz. Wer denn eigentlich? Du hast nämlich das Podcast-Ofo geschrieben, wie jemand, der Twitter zum ersten. Ach scheiße, das ist aber auch, ach fuck, ich wusste es, dass ich irgendwas falsch gemacht habe. Und danach hast du nochmal geantwortet, aber zweimal. Ach scheiße, egal, fuck, das könnte es ja auch tun. Was war da los? Das war die Online-Reaktion, damit habe ich ja gar nichts mehr zu tun tatsächlich. Aber da hat jemand Einstein beleidigt und da möchte ich mal ganz kurz eine Lanz für Einstein brechen, denn Einstein hat gesagt, niemand schlägt Roulette. Das hat Einstein gesagt, nebenbei bei irgendeinem Kaffeetrinken oder so, haben ein Kumpel gesagt am Telefon, so als er hat es immer als Verabschiedung gesagt, so, dann mach's gut, ne, und niemand schlägt Roulette, ne, ciao! Ja, oder er hat es bei Scrubble irgendwie gelegt, die drei Wörter, niemand schlägt und Roulette, hier 87, und man hat es mitgeschrieben oder so. Oh, stell dir vor, es wäre wirklich siebenundachtzig Punkte. Jemand würde es nachrechnen, dass es genau siebenundachtzig Punkte sind und dich nach Posthum zu einem Genie erklären. Posthum. Klüger als Posthum? Posthum. Was ist Posthum? Posthum ist, glaube ich, einfach danach oder nicht. Also fort oder sowas. Ach so. Und Posthum ist nach dem Tun. Ja, ich meinte ja auch Posthum. Es wäre auch cool, wenn jemand mal alle unsere Anfangsbestaben zusammennehme und da kommt irgendwie raus irgendwie Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn ist auch ein okayer Podcast. Ich glaube, wir benutzen zu wenig Umlaute. Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn, ja. Okay, alles klar, wow. Gut, die Grammatische Redaktion wieder versagt an der Stelle. Nee,ache ist was Tolles. Man überlegt sich ja oft, wie die Welt für Leute aussieht, die eine andere Sprache denken. Mega interessant. Ich habe darüber nachgedacht. Danke. Das ganze Woche, sorry, wenn du jetzt irgendwie... Nee, bitte. Das ist eine geile Soda-Ausweite. Nein, mach nur. Ich habe über die Teletubbies nachgedacht. Die Teletubbies sind echt, ich glaube, die sind krass unterschätzt. Also die eine Theorie ist, dass es einfach Pädagogen waren, die überlegt haben, okay, wie bringen wir, das sieht ja so ganz anders aus aus alles, was man kennt. Und Erwachsene mögen das auch nicht, weil das komplett anders ist als alles, was man erwartet für Kinder. Weil es halt komplett auf sie geht und komplett wie sie spricht, wie die Kinder. Und es die ganze Zeit, es wirkt halt, als hätten Pädagogen sich zusammengesetzt und nur für Kinder eine Sendung gemacht, auch die Wiederholung mit der Babysonne und so, aber ich glaube, da steckt mehr dahinter. Also es sind nicht einfach nur Pädagogen, die sich überlegt haben, gut, und das macht Sinn, wenn wir das nochmal wiederholen, sondern ich glaube, man hat doch, wenn man dann, wenn man da was machen würde, würde man schon einen Plan dahinter stecken. Die Stefan Titzes Nein-Gin-Gag-Theorie der Woche. So, bitte. Die Sonne, ähm, echt jetzt? Fafort. Ehrlich jetzt? Fafort. Die Sonne oben, so als eine Art Gottheit, die für Kinder steht, für alle Kinder, die unterhalten werden wollen einfach. Und dann leben die in ihrer komischen, surrealen Gartenwelt, leben dann diese vier Dinger. Aber ganz kurz nochmal, also die Teletubbies hatten ja Fernseher im Bauch oder auf dem Bauch. Ja, das ist nur alles random. Aber da liefen auch manchmal dann Sachen in den Bauchfernseher. Ja, und boring Sachen halt einfach. Aber so Einsendungen von den Zuschauern, oder? Ja, ja, glaub schon. Sowas, ne? Ich finde das so gruselig, weil die reden ja auch nicht richtig miteinander. Ja. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Sozialexperiment, die haben vier Alienswesen so aufwachsen lassen, ohne Sprache. Also entwickeln, hat man mal Menschen in einem Raum, also vier Menschen einfach aufwachsen lassen zusammen, abgeschnitten von der Auferenwelt? Ich glaube, es gab mal ein Experiment von so einem Kind, das in so einer Tonne aufgewachsen ist, aber das kommt ja durchgedreht und ist dann auch gestorben, ja. Du, glaube ich. Nee, aber entwickeln Kinder dann, wenn angenommen zwei Kinder wachsen in einem Raum auf, entwickeln die eine Sprache? Das ist eine interessante Frage. Weiß ich nicht, die können jetzt glaube ich nur theoretisch antworten. Das ist so ein Sozialexperiment, weil die kriegen ja nur Tabby Toast und Tabby Pudding, aber nur zu speziellen Zeiten. Und ab und zu kommen diese komischen Rohre aus dem Boden gefahren und sagen denen, was sie machen sollen. Die leben in einer ganz absurden Welt. Ganz jetziger Welt, ne? Also das sind wahrscheinlich alles Metaphern für irgendwas, ne? Ja, ich glaube, das sind einfach Geiseln, so Unterhaltungssklaven. Ja. Aber ich finde es echt gruselig, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, dass er mehr hintersteckt als nur dieses für Kinder gemacht. Ja, du, ich sag mal so, wenn die AfD jetzt die Macht übernimmt und halt irgendwie neue Konzentrationslager baut und sowas, dann könnten medizinische Ideen wie diese einfach umgesetzt werden. Würdest du flüchten, wenn das passieren würde? Nein. Aus der Welt, aus Deutschland? Nein, ich würde Widerstandskämpfen. Ich würde hier einen auf Anne Frank machen und zehn Jahre im Dachboden leben. Dann will ich immer gucken, was sie dann noch machen. Du gehst auch trainieren jetzt, ne? Ich trainiere für den Ernstfall. Gehst du deswegen trainieren? Ich trainiere für den Ernstfall, falls die AfD die Macht übernimmt, dass ich den Reichstag stürmen kann. Falls dann die AfD mal bevor du steht mit so einem Schlag. Ja, hau ich um, hau ich klein. Den Klotsch mal zum, oder? Dafür stemmst, wie viel stemmst du jetzt so? Ich stemme überhaupt nichts, gar nichts. Aber, ne, tatsächlich, weil ich habe letztens so eine Doku über Auschwitz gesehen. Gibt es eine gute Doku nur über Auschwitz, zehnteilige Doku auf Netflix, wo er auch dann dieser Wissenschaftler, hier Mendel, nee, nee, warte, schneid es kurz raus, meine Denkpause, weil mir einfällt, wie der heißt. Mann, fuck you. Wenn wir alle unsere Denkpausen mal rausschneiden würden, dann würden dann würden wir so auf Zack. Aber wenn wir auf Zack wären wir da. Wie heißt nochmal der Satz? Es gibt kein schlechtes Bier nicht, weil auch jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein gutes Bier zu brauen. Es gibt gar schlechtes Bier nicht. Bisschen weniger ukrainisch, aber nutzt aber schon gut. Es gibt gar schlechtes Bier nicht. Mängele! Ja. Ich sag euch, es gibt kein schlechtes Bier nicht, weil jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein gutes Bier zu brauen. Aber warum rollst du das R dabei nicht jetzt so? Weil meine Bayern-Imitation rollt ein R.
Ja, aber nicht bei jedem R. Also du hast ja tatsächlich beim Bayerischen tatsächlich einen Sonderfall, du hast ja das linguale R, du hast ja das Zungen-R, du kannst ja das R auf zwei Arten sprechen, du hast das guturale R, das du sozusagen hinten im Hals sprichst. Das Reiber-R. Das Reiber-R. Genau, und dann das linguale R mit der Zunge. Rrr. Rrr. Das hast du im Deutschen so gut wie gar nicht. Das hast du zum Beispiel mit einem türkischen Akzent hast du das. Ja, da benutzen die das Zungen-R. Döner. Nee, dann sowas wie... Dürrüm.
Dürrüm.
Altar war... Ja, also es ist im arabischen Raum, glaube ich, hast du das und sowas in der Richtung. Adwa Akbar. Nee, das ist ja echt den so. Altar, ey, was willst du? Sowas. Aber da ist kein R drin, weißt du, das ist problematisch. Aber lass uns den gesamten Teil einfach nochmal rausschneiden. Aber im Bayerischen und im Bayerischen hast du tatsächlich, als, glaube ich, einziger Dialekt Deutschlands, hast du das Zungen-R drin, zum Beispiel bei Grirsti.
Grirsti, hast du das Zungen-R, das ist kein Grirsti, sondern Grirsti.
Grirsti.
Hast du vorne, hast du vorne bei der Zunge.
Das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen falsch. Grirsti.
Grirsti.
Grirsti, da hast du das Zungen-R vorne mit drin.
Und das ist ganz abgefahren, weil das hast du, glaube ich, kein... Senora. Senora, ja genau, da hast du es zum Beispiel drin. Paella, überall, in jedem Wort. Ja, aber das ist interessant, weil man kann das einfach nicht gut nachmachen. Aber das hast du auch nicht immer. Das ist ein bisschen weird. Ich habe mal auch so einen Hardcore-Bayer getroffen, der hat dann zum Beispiel Corr gesagt. Also Coror hat er dann immer das R so krass betont. Ja, aber das ist kein Dialekt, das ist einfach falsch. Das ist einfach falsch. Der hat dann auch einen Schlagentfall tatsächlich. Das ist einfach falsch. Genau, und ja, aber du rollst nicht automatisch jedes R im Bayerischen. Ja genau, das passt natürlich schwierig, die Imitation des Bayern für mich macht es fast unmöglich. Selbst für allen grossen Imitatoren. Ich finde, du hast das schon ganz gut gemacht. Zurück zu Auschwitz, wo ja dann tatsächlich dieser Doktor Mengele kam und gesagt, Leute, was für eine geile Situation gerade, die bringen hier Leute um, super gut, stalte ich mich mit ein und mache halt Experimente an Menschen, was man halt davor nicht machen konnte, jetzt geht das plötzlich, jetzt kann man das machen. So ein ganzes wissenschaftlichen Trieb zu sagen, jetzt ist halt gerade die Zeit, wo man sowas machen kann. Jetzt lass uns einfach mal klar, natürlich ist das alles nicht so cool, aber lass uns einfach mal drei Jahre lang so alle Experimente mit Menschen machen, dann können wir das auch lassen, dann kommen wieder hier, kommen die anderen so, aber lass uns einfach mal durchziehen. Was haben die denn gemacht? Der hat dann zum Beispiel, der hat ja Zwillinge und hat dann immer das Problem, an Zwillingen kannst du ja gut Sachen testen,
weil wenn du dem einen eine Medizin gibst und dem anderen nicht,
hast du halt immer so einen Vergleichswert, weil die halt genau gleich sind.
Das Problem ist nur, du willst die Kinder ja, du willst sie möglichst ja auch einer Autopsie unterziehen.
Das heißt, du willst sie untersuchen, wenn die tot sind.
Das geht aber nicht, weil unter normalen Umständen Zwillinge nicht gleichzeitig sterben.
Allerdings im KZ sind die Regeln anders. Da kannst du so einem Kind so eine Medizin geben, das wäre mega makaber eigentlich, und dann wenn es stirbt, kannst du sagen, ah, ist tot, lass das andere schnell auch umbringen und dann beide eine Autopsie durchführen, dann können wir nämlich an der Leiche genau feststellen, wie diese Mittel gewirkt haben und die Unterschiede herausfinden. Weil da hast du die Möglichkeit, Leute aktiv umzubringen, eben in Konzentrationslagern. Aber was haben die noch gemacht? Die haben alle durch die Scheiss gemacht und halt dann so auch... Die hätten ja schon interessante Sachen machen können, das ging jetzt nicht verkaber, aber... Ja, die haben auch so grossen, halt so lauter sadistischen Scheiss gemacht und halt so Waffen getestet und so ein Kram. Warum haben die nicht geklont? Ja, weil es glaube ich... Oder Sex im Weltall oder sowas. Ja, klar, natürlich. Ja, oder drei Köpfe oder sowas. Klar, hätte man alles machen können. Aber Nazis sind auch wahnsinnig dämlich einfach, muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Die sind einfach schon ziemlich dumm. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, die machen nicht das Beste aus ihren Dingen. So die Grundlage ist schon okay, aber dann einfach nicht weitergedacht. So Brainstorming zu früh abgebrochen. Oder drei Schritte zu viel in die richtige Richtung. Kann auch sein. Ja, nochmal einen Schritt zurück. So Leute, wäre doch auch gut, wenn Hitler gesagt hat, so klar, Juden nicht so geil, aber KZ war ein bisschen zu krass. Oder lass uns da nochmal einen Schritt zurückgehen. Sorry, so lass uns da mal gucken. Aber tatsächlich, Mengene hat viel an Zwillingen gearbeitet, tatsächlich. Er hat alle Zwillinge zusammengesammelt und dann gesagt, so Leute, auf geht's. Ja, bisschen makaber tatsächlich. Das ist jetzt so ein Moment, wo ich im Nachhinein nicht weiß, ob wir den rausschneiden sollten oder nicht, der Scheren-Moment, ich würde es gerne als Scheren-Phänomen bezeichnen, dieses auf der Kippe, dieses je nachdem, wie wir das jetzt noch weiterhin besprechen, lassen wir es kommentiert, unkommentiert, kann es natürlich jetzt, kann es drüber sein oder kann es okay sein? Es ist wie im Jazz. Man weiss nicht, was kommt. Ein guter Freund von mir, der gleichzeitig Jazzmusiker ist, mit dem ich lange Jahre tatsächlich Musik gemacht habe, hat mir mal gesagt, weisst du, im Jazz ist es so, eine falsche Note wird erst dann falsch, wenn die nächste Note auch falsch ist, wenn die nächste Note auch ein Fehler ist. Du kannst immer einen Fehler dadurch retten, dass du anders nach dem Fehler weiterspielst und sozusagen dadurch eine neue Melodie erzeugst, einen neuen Rhythmus, eine neue Situation und dadurch machst du den Fehler wieder weg. Verstehst du? Nicht so richtig, also man kann ja einfach, ich glaube es ist einfach, wenn du Fehler selbstbewusst stehen lässt. Ja, aber wenn du ihn stehen lässt, dann ist es ja als Fehler, kommt es ja raus. Wenn du halt zum Beispiel, du spielst dreimal das gleiche und beim zweiten Mal ist es falsch, dann weiss jeder, es ist falsch. So 12-Ton-Musik, einfach nur, er hat sie direkt beim ersten Ton verspielt, hat dann einfach alles, alles einfach nur random Töne nacheinander gespielt und gesagt, okay, das war der Plan, ich hab mir nicht verspielt, das war die Idee. Das sollte gar nicht schön klicken, das sollte nur alle. Da, da, genau. Und es ist eine Metapher, mein Gott, es geht nur darum, dass du deine Fehler noch retten kannst, wenn du dann halt nicht sagst, oh scheiße, waren Fehler, ich geb auf, sondern halt anders weitermachst. Und ich glaube, in so einer Situation sind wir auch gerade. Die KZ-Auschwitz-Mängel-Geschichte war ein Fehler, aber wenn wir jetzt geschmackvoll weitermachen und du vielleicht irgendwie noch eine romantische Geschichte aus deinem Privatleben erzählst, glaube ich, kommen wir da gut drüber weg. Es ist Karneval. Du isst gerade eine Herzschokolade und ich habe gemerkt, dass sich in deinem Leben einiges verändert hat. Lass uns doch mal ein bisschen Einblick in Stefan Titzes Liebesleben werfen. Was ist da passiert? Wie hast du Karneval erlebt? Gab es da Begegnungen für dich, Momente, die dir in Erinnerung geblieben sind?
Möchtest du dir eine Gegenfrage stellen?
Nee.
Du bist als Smetbo gegangen, Karneval, und gestern auf der krassen Karnevalsfeier war Smetbo
plötzlich weg mit der Anna, die als Pirat gegangen ist. Ja, es war ein verrückter Abend. Es war ein interessantes Rollenspiel tatsächlich zwischen Smedbo und Piraten. Hat nicht ganz ruhig, die besprechen eine andere Sprache. Ich habe die ganze Nacht nach einem Safcon gesucht, einfach damit es so ein bisschen im gleichen Universum ist tatsächlich. Aber die Piratin ist es geworden tatsächlich. War interessant, da musste man ein bisschen improvisieren. Ich finde es bei einem Karneval ja nicht gut, dass die Leute, ich habe auch schon mal gesagt, oder dass Leute das nicht durchhalten, einfach ihre Rollen. Die fallen so schnell raus einfach. Und heute auch der Ghostbusters-Typ, der mich nach der Poststrasse gefragt hat, zieh es durch, wenn du heute unter der Brücke pennst. Ganz im Ernst, aber ein Ghostbuster fragt nicht, wo die Poststrasse ist. Nein, und Kylo Ren hat kein blaues Lichtschwert, weißt du, da stehen Leute und dann denkst du einfach, was ist denn hier los, warum vergleifst du dich als eine Star Wars Figur, wenn du auf sich keine Ahnung von Star Wars hast? Ja, und der ist auch in Jerry Seinfeld, der Superman trägt auch keinen Anorak an. Ja, klar. Friere, your feelings! Ja, genau. So gut. Ich wollte jetzt gerade, glaube ich, einen Tweet raushauen, dieses Jahr gehe ich halt so Anorak einfach, weil im Endeffekt ist die… Hast du das nicht mehr rausgehauen? Letztes Jahr tatsächlich, glaube ich, aber der kam nicht so gut an, weil jedes Kostüm ist im Endeffekt Anorak, ist einfach Mütze, Anorak und dann halt so Spider-Man-Beine. Oh, über Bande, nicht schlecht. Ich habe eben einen Papierknäuel in Müllheim getroffen. Ja, ich bin müde, ich würde ganz gerne schlafen gehen. Ich wünsche dir noch eine schöne Woche. Dankeschön. Ich freue mich, dass es wieder geklappt hat, dass wir wieder an die richtige Seite gesprochen haben. Werden wir sehen. Das ist auch ein Blöd, dass man das im Nachhinein merkt, dass man Fehler gemacht hat. Aber gut, That's how life works. Florentin, Stefan, vielen Dank dafür.
Vielen Dank.
Mach's gut, tschau siebauen.
Und wir sehen uns zum nächsten Mal.
Und wir heben ab.
Ich hebe ab.